and Tory asks as I launch the shift in
paperback what were the three most
effective things you did to drive book
sales Tory thinks in a question really
was excited to put your your question on
on the show because I just really want
the maniacs to know about you I'm a fan
we've done some events together good
luck with the book without knowing the
true context of the book though and and
everybody will have to do their own
homework on that part there's a couple
secrets I have for everybody who wants
to write a book that have really worked
for me and they're not really secrets
it's actually quite boring my belief is
that you actually sell your book a year
too before you're actually selling your
book by providing by the global Jab Jab
Jab right hook here's an example Tory
I'm actually selling my fourth book
right now I'm putting out a show every
day I'm taking time which is my number
one asset
I like time I like time more than money
I prefer time which had a watch over
cash that's how valuable it is and Here
I am taking time every day out to just
answer questions to provide value to
give value to entertain to give an
answer to make somebody think to provide
value in their entrepreneurial venture
to the people that have been me worth
their time thank you and so you know I'm
selling my fourth book right now because
I'm providing value to a whole new
audience as a matter of fact a quick
question of the day leave in the
comments section if you've discovered me
because of askgaryvee that'll be
interesting to see what happens to
comments please do that if you are don't
be a lurker how many use that's her in a
long time so that's number one number
two and this is a big unknown thing to a
lot of people it surprises me how many
people have not figured this out people
don't want more content as much as they
want more access everybody wants to do
book offers where if you buy three books
you can get a free ebook or this that
more content right get into this what
they want is access one of the biggest
things that I did Tory that really sold
a lot of books for me was give myself to
the audience if you did this many books
or bought this many books I would do
this live stream Q&A I would come to
your school I
make a video for happy birthday I would
literally give sell the number one thing
people want from me which is more access
and it's the thing you want from
everybody that you appreciate you want
to spend more time with that person
those are two I'm giving you I'm not
giving you a third one because those are
the two that matter